[Music]
americans are filled with dread as store
shelves are empty as the president's
head
and their solution for this mess
is you expecting less
yeah the economy is heading for ruin but
be happy we're becoming the soviet union
so here's some major concerns that any
average american might have this week
you got a supply chain crisis crushing
businesses and consumers secret late
night flights to new york carrying
underage migrants by the way the last
time democrats booked flights like that
it was with jeffrey epstein
oh
how dare you and a trillion-dollar
spending bill that will drag down the
entire country seems like a good time
for the white house to provide some
clarity right jen
it was crystal clear that things were
not improving on supply chain people
couldn't get dishwashers and
and furniture and treadmills delivered
on time not to mention all sorts of
other things
so why is the tragedy of the short the
treadmill that's delayed why is the
administration flying thousands of
migrants from the border to florida and
new york in the middle of the night
uh well i'm not sure that it's in the
middle of the night it is our 4 29 a.m
well very early in the morning here we
are talking about early flights earlier
than you might like to take a flight
details still believe that
better will not add a dime to the
national debt
correct it won't why would why should
americans believe that because it won't
i gotta hand it to her she really looks
on the bright side of things her glass
is half full which is better than our
grocery shelves i wonder if she's like
that all the time
[Music]
[Music]
like i just stole my bag well that's
great uh now you won't have to uh carry
it and your posture will probably um
improve but white house press secretary
ken saki that bag had my wallet in it
well now it's been redistributed to that
underprivileged um criminal uh kind of
selfish of you to uh keep those snacks
they're all i could afford honest
you know i wish i had that positive
outlook but it's no wonder team biden is
okay with this when you're in cognitive
decline you don't remember the better
times
of course the media is totally behind
biden's strategy a wapo that's short for
washington post which kind of makes the
whole wapo redundant when i say it's the
washington post twice
an op-ed argues that you shouldn't
complain about lack of services or labor
shortages instead just lower your
expectations you adults
look you don't have to wait in line for
bread if you don't want to you can just
starve
or embrace the weight
and besides raising expectations means
the government actually has to do work
instead let's lower them we even made
you a handy video to help more americans
get on board
hey there kiddos have you heard about
the so-called national supply chain
crisis well there's a lot of
misinformation going around but the
truth is with the shortage of goods
there's never been a better time to
lower your life's expectations
sure there might be breadlines but hey
what a great way to meet your neighbors
no toilet paper on the shelves no
problem remember you're also eating much
less
rising gas prices that means less money
for your crippling pill addiction isn't
it time you got clean anyway
and less driving is a great way to get
your steps in for the day comrade you
see kids the sooner you learn to love
sovietization the sooner you'll come to
the realization that the american dream
was a nightmare and remember you've had
it too easy for too long
who easy
too long charlie
it's kind of interesting it doesn't seem
that sacky is that her name saki yeah
hasn't isn't even trying anymore it's as
though she the me the media has lowered
their expectations for her and she's
meeting them well yeah and in a lot of
ways she's like she's like the perfect
press secretary for this administration
completely out of her depth completely
has no idea what she's talking about on
a regular basis and then uh but the
worst of course is when she comes up
with the with the funny quips and she
tries to do the same comedy uh it's
insulting it's uh ridiculous and
obviously it's not funny um and in one
of those clips i can't remember if if
you showed it right there where she's
she's talking about the supply chain and
she says you know we're not the post
office right and it's like well actually
uh
you are
but
and it's terrible yeah but um but it's
also you know and it's also a reminder
of uh talk about silver linings um you
know there there was a great silver
lining uh
you know in in being in a 40-year
nuclear standoff with the soviet union
we were reminded of what socialism
really was like yeah we had we had to
read up on it yeah and people talked
about it yeah and then and people that
would escape would tell you stories
about breadlines and i guess we're just
gonna have to like you know whatever 40
30 years later we're just going to have
to discover it on our own it'll be a fun
time give it out an adventure charlie
yeah that's what i do with everything
bad joe if you marry jensaki her name
would be joe sakimaki
[Applause]
i'm getting applause from laura logan
over that terrible joke
don't you have a question greg that my
question is why haven't you married
shinsaki
i believe she's taken and i'm an
honorable man
uh you get to live a life of lowered
expectations
so what is your what's your feeling i
like lower expectations great that's why
that treadmill equip landed for me
because
if there's no treadmills then i've got
the perfect excuse for why i don't have
to use a treadmill
i just think you know people aren't
stupid when you're trying to put
lipstick on a pig except right now
there's not much lipstick or pig
[Laughter]
and the the other thing that i found
really insulting was people saying that
uh with gensake's saying that oh this is
a sign that the economy is picking up
that the goods are in short supply it's
like no i wasn't waiting to buy
food
[Laughter]
i'm always looking to buy food
that's true
that's a very good point damn it i wish
i came up with that cat your entire
dating life was uh had the was focused
on low expectations
yeah but then it changed i have been
married now for almost six months
thanks yeah that's a half a year
i know sorry anybody who might have lost
money
um
but yeah it's just reading that article
is absurd you can't say that ever like
imagine if a therapist said that yeah
has it ever occurred to you that you
should just accept swinging between
debilitating anxiety and crushing
depression like
i mean you'd have to only go to one
session but other than that yes
that's not effective no it's not and
nobody and you try to push you know jen
sake you push her on these things and
she goes cuz yeah
i couldn't do that yeah i couldn't you
know you couldn't do that say something
someone pushing you well why well cuz
yeah
we wouldn't still have jobs but yet she
does yeah that's true you know laura you
like low expectations are what you
expect when you leave america you've
been all over the world like so you've
seen some pretty bad stuff are we
overstating this no not at all in fact
what's happening here is that i think
jen saki has just she's just run out of
energy there's so many crises all over
the place it's all coming apart the
tactics are failing you know they've
done the whole tactic of we're going to
i mean they're running out of labels
right it's either the q and on or it's
the white supremacist or it's the
anti-vaxx terrorist i mean it's
something like that and uh it's just not
working anymore americans uh people are
smart and they see through it and they
know when they go uh to walmart sorry i
live in a town of 11 000 people we we're
lucky to have one in walmart and they
know when they can't get the things that
they need and they know the fact that
it's all made in china is a problem and
they're they're not stupid and they're
not falling for the whole treadmill
thing yeah you know and also you know
what it is it's consistent with a much
more significant strategy if you never
acknowledge that it's a crisis you never
actually have to do anything about it
look at them the borders not a crisis
right exactly and so they don't have to
do anything about it the afghanistan
that wasn't a crisis that was a historic
movement of people right so we don't
have to do anything about the fact that
we torched an entire nation right and
we're isolated on the world stage at the
exact moment that china's launching its
supersonic right around the world
missile right and so on and this just
keeps going because the supply chain
crisis is exposing the fact that we
don't make anything anymore yeah and we
don't make enough to feed america but
don't worry they're going to kill all
the animals and they're going to give
you food made in a a factory right yeah
you don't know what's in it but bill
gates has got you he's got your back
that's i'm all for the factory uh animal
thing though because uh
just sounds tasty
what am i saying i'm joking hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else